David Boder: [In English] France, September the 12th, 1946, at Hénonville, about fifty kilometers from Paris. A Kibbutz in a wonderful countryside, in an old castle, for displaced Jews. The interviewee is Mrs. Clara Neiman, a woman who was converted, I understand, to Judaism. And so, Mrs. Neiman.
David Boder: [In Russian] [пауза] мадам Найман, скажите нам опять, как Ваша полная фамилия и...
Clara Neiman: Най...
David Boder: . . . и скажите, сколько Вам лет.
Clara Neiman: Найман.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Найман Клара.
Clara Neiman: 25 лет.
David Boder: 25 лет?
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: А где Вы родились, мадам Найман?
Clara Neiman: Город Саратов.
David Boder: Так. Как Вас по отчеству зовут?
Clara Neiman: Адамовна.
David Boder: Клара Адамовна?
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Клара Адамовна, Вы родились в Саратове.
David Boder: И у Вас была большая семья?
Clara Neiman: Большая.
David Boder: Большая семья была.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: И сколько же человек: отец, мать...
Clara Neiman: Семеро нас было...нет, нет, десятеро всех с матери.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Семеро детей.
David Boder: Так, семеро детей...и отец...
Clara Neiman: Отец и мать.
David Boder: Тогда же девять.
Clara Neiman: Девять, да. А еще один был и (неразборчиво) умерший.
David Boder: Ага, да, значит один...Всего у Вашей матери было восемь детей?
Clara Neiman: Восемь детей [неразборчиво]
David Boder: А скажите, где Вы были...так...и Ваши родители были какого вероисповедания?
Clara Neiman: Они были...были русские, потом перешедшие в евреи.
David Boder: Родители тоже?!
Clara Neiman: Родители были русские, но мы уже рожденные евреи.
David Boder: Я понимаю.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: И Ваши родители тоже перешли в евреи?
Clara Neiman: Перешли в евреи.
David Boder: Как это случилось?
Clara Neiman: [Неразборчиво] так, они захотели приобщения к еврейской веры.
David Boder: Ваши родители?!
Clara Neiman: Да, мои родители. Они же в Палестину уехали.
David Boder: Уже Ваши родители в Палестине?
Clara Neiman: В Палестине, да.
David Boder: А скажите, сколько же лет тому назад Ваши родители перешли в еврейство?
Clara Neiman: Это приблизительно двадцать лет уже.
David Boder: И они прожили все это время в России?
Clara Neiman: Нет, не в России. Жили в Баку, в Грузии.
David Boder: О...
Clara Neiman: В Грузии. Кавказ.
David Boder: На Кавказе?
Clara Neiman: Да, на Кавказе.
David Boder: А что, Ваш отец и мать обе были рожденные русские?
Clara Neiman: Русские были рожденные, перешедшие. Ну, а мы уже, значит...например, я уже нет еще, но уже остальные все,  я и старший брат лишь только не рожденные...рожденные токо...мама перешла.
David Boder: Ваша мать...
Clara Neiman: Мама уже как еврейка была. Понятно?
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Когда Вы родились?
Clara Neiman: Да, и когда я родилась. Ну, год там или два назад, позже.
David Boder: So, afterwards.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Значит, Вас уже не крестили?
Clara Neiman: Нет, нет, нас уже нет. Мы уже были как еврейские дети [неразборчиво].
David Boder: А Вы не можете объяснить, каким это образом Ваши родители решили перейти...
Clara Neiman: Как они решили? Они перешли...они не были русскими, русскими не были.
David Boder: Так, так.
Clara Neiman: Они были сектанты.
David Boder: Аа, они были сектанты. Какой секты?
Clara Neiman: Секта другая, да. Вы слышали наверно.
David Boder: Да, конечно.
Clara Neiman: Они были...эээ...молокан. Точно, молокан.
David Boder: Аа, они были из молокан.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Так. И потом...
Clara Neiman: И потом посчитали, что нужно перейти в еврейство, это не не...не настоящая вера, значит...они [неразборчиво] потом перешли в субботники, и настоящие евреи, так.
David Boder: И Вы сперва в субботники перешли?
Clara Neiman: Нет...стали субботники, а потом уже...значит все...все, что нужно...еврейский закон весь приняли.
David Boder: Так. Много там было в этой...в этом месте?
Clara Neiman: Семьдесят человек, всех приняли тогда. Семьдесят...семьдесят семей.
David Boder: Семьдесят семей...?
Clara Neiman: Семьдесят семей переехало в евреи. Когда мама переходила.
David Boder: Уже двадцать лет тому назад?
Clara Neiman: Уже двадцать лет тому назад.
David Boder: Так, а...
Clara Neiman: . . . и многие геры наши уже там, в Палестине, в Тель-Авиве теперь живут. В 24-ом году уехали.
David Boder: Уехали в 24-ом году?
Clara Neiman: Да, в 24-ом году уехали. Еще Тель-Авив не был даже построен.
David Boder: А как они тогда из России выбрались?
Clara Neiman: Они...эээ...черные границы переходили.
David Boder: Черные границы  переходили?
Clara Neiman: Черные границы.
David Boder: Ну, а скажите мне, Клара Адамовна...эээ...где Вы были, когда началась война.
Clara Neiman: Мы были в Грузии, город Кутаис.
David Boder: Но вы сами не кавказцы?
Clara Neiman: Нет, нет, мы вышли из [неразборчиво] Саратова, там мы были рожденные.
David Boder: Вы родились не в Саратове...?
Clara Neiman: Мы переехали. Остальные дети были на Украине тоже рожденные. На Украине тоже мы жили.
David Boder: А как же Вы в Грузию попали?
Clara Neiman: А мы в Грузию попали еще перед...эээ...перед войной...еще пять лет до войны было...
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: В войну мы были все время в Грузии [неразборчиво]...пять лет как мы...до войны еще.
David Boder: Так. А как Вы решили...зачем решили в Грузию поехать?
Clara Neiman: В России очень было трудно жить.
David Boder: Кому?
Clara Neiman: Вообще, нам было очень трудно жить.
David Boder: А в Грузии?
Clara Neiman: . . . нельзя было провести еврейство как нужно...а уж религию нельзя было провести, а мама [неразборчиво] таким образом, что там были у нас знакомые...до нас перешедшие тоже были, переехали в Грузию. И они решили, значит, узнать, а потом мы переехали в Грузию.
David Boder: Ага. И...эээ...Советы вам позволили переехать в Грузию?
Clara Neiman: Да, они ничего...против этого ничего не имели. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: А скажите, Грузия ведь тоже Советская?
Clara Neiman: Грузия Советская, но там [неразборчиво] удобнее было жить. Там зимы не было...
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: . . . одежа была очень дешево...
Clara Neiman: . . . было получше жить.
David Boder: Было получше жить все равно.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: И Вы что там, крестьянами были или чем?
Clara Neiman: Нет, я занималась трикотажем, папа был тоже на производстве и все братья тоже были на производстве, сестра тоже...
David Boder: Все работали?
Clara Neiman: Да. Сестра моя тоже здесь, семья её тоже здесь, [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Сестра Ваша тоже здесь?
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Так, а...
Clara Neiman: Мы не могли выехать [неразборчиво] нелегально, потому что трудно было с детями. У них двое было детей, у меня один ребёнок маленький.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: И мы еще не уехали потому.
David Boder: Так, Вы думаете нелегально в Палестину не могли выехать?
Clara Neiman: Не могли. Мама выехала нелегально, с папой, и братья, и сестра взрослая уже.
David Boder: В Тель-Авив?
Clara Neiman: Да, они живут в сейчас уже в Тель-Авив. Месяц уже как живут в Тель-Авив, освобожденные, на воле.
David Boder: Ага.
Clara Neiman: А мы не могли поехать...
David Boder: . . . были освобожденные. Их что, держали в...
Clara Neiman: Они в лагере были.
David Boder: Ага, а потом их освободили.
Clara Neiman: Да. Была очень трудная дорога, даже без воды тоже были три дня.
David Boder: Угу. Так вот Вы мне скажите, когда...Вы говорите в эту сторону немножко, это так...
Clara Neiman: Да, да, да, я извиняюсь.
David Boder: Так, скажите-ка, когда война началась, Вы были в Кутаисе.
Clara Neiman: Да, город Кутаис.
David Boder: Ну, теперь расскажите мне...
Clara Neiman: . . . еврейский большой город.
David Boder: Еврейский?!
Clara Neiman: Да, еврейский город. [Неразборчиво] евреев было там, семьдесят синагог было - такой большой выбор.
David Boder: В Кутаисе?
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Каким образом?
Clara Neiman: Очень большой выбор. Как?! Очень большой город, это еврейский город! Батум – это недалеко - тоже так. Это возле [неразборчиво].
David Boder: А что, евреи там из [неразборчиво] были?
Clara Neiman: Русские, грузинские евреи; там разные нации были евреи. Русские...русские были евреи и грузины...очень набожные евреи, полны все синагоги были.
David Boder: В Кутаисе?
Clara Neiman: Да, в Кутаисе. Потому мы уехали из России.
David Boder: Ага, понятно.
Clara Neiman: В России очень трудно было провести религию.
David Boder: В России религия была [неразборчиво]?
Clara Neiman: Да, очень трудно было. Запрещали, там это все запретили. В последнее время было открыто уже, как сообщили в газетах уже, значит, из Англии, из Америки [неразборчиво]. Перед...после войны, можно сказать уже. Перед войной [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Так, значит, война началась, Вы были в Кутаисе.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Ну, теперь Вы мне подробно расскажите, как это все это что случилось? Где Вы были во время войны? И как Вы в конце концов в Париж попали? Не торопитесь, у нас есть время.
Clara Neiman: Ага, хорошо. Это как бы, я... значит, когда мы были в Кутаис, я вышла замуж за поляка.
David Boder: За поляка.
Clara Neiman: За поляка-еврея. Мой муж поляк-еврей.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: И у сестры тоже так.
Clara Neiman: И потом вот мы решили поехать в Польшу.
David Boder: Ага.
Clara Neiman: Я токо поехала в Польшу, а мама осталася и сестра там, в город Кутаисе. Сестра тоже еще была там.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Вся наша семья. Сестра тоже вышла в город Кутаис замуж.
David Boder: А как же польские евреи попали...
Clara Neiman: Они были в Грузии. Очень много было в Грузии....
David Boder: Польских евреев.
Clara Neiman: Да, польских евреев очень много, от войны бежавшие, да.
David Boder: А, это было, когда...
Clara Neiman: Это было...во время уже войны. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Они эвакуировались и отправились в Грузию.
Clara Neiman: Да, третий год, как я вышла замуж.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Три года.
David Boder: Так, так. А он был эвакуирован, Ваш [неразборчиво]?
Clara Neiman: Он был эвакуирован [неразборчиво]. Многие были.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: И мы там хупе сделали, значит, город Кутаис....
David Boder: Вы что сделали?
Clara Neiman: Хупе, ну обыкновенную свадьбу.
David Boder: Так. Nu?
Clara Neiman: И потом мы решили уехать в Польшу. [неразборчиво] до окончания войны.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: В первый год окончания войны мы решили выехать в Польшу.
Clara Neiman: И мы вырешили выехать с мужем в Польшу. Побыли мы, так скажем, пять месяцев. Потом приехала мама. Я вызвала маму, что, значит, написала [неразборчиво] таким типа текстом, раньше нельзя было писать...
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: . . . чтобы мама приехала, что можно возможно мы выедем там в Палестину.
Clara Neiman: Только [неразборчиво] написала, чтобы это...письмо это могло дойти. Вам понятно, что же.
David Boder: Да, так, чтобы цензура прошла.
Clara Neiman: Да. И потом...эээ...значит, в конце концов, мама приезжает ко мне на зиму.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Приезжает мама...
David Boder: Куда? Где Вы жили в Польше?
Clara Neiman: В Польше? В город Лодзь.
David Boder: Лодзь?!
Clara Neiman: Петроковска 23.
David Boder: Город Лодзь?
Clara Neiman: Да, на главной улице Петраковской 23 мы жили.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Ну, ничего. Мой муж портной. Мы хорошо стали зарабатывать, но все-таки же большой антисемитизм и очень стали много евреев убивать. Тогда в России были [неразборчиво]...
David Boder: Погромы?
Clara Neiman: Погромы.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Потом я написала маме письмо. Она при...значит, на зиму, они решили выехать. Сестра и мама, значит, всей семьей они выехали. Приехали ко мне.
David Boder: В Палестину?
Clara Neiman: Нет, к нам.
David Boder: И с куда еще?
Clara Neiman: Город...с Грузии [пауза] в Польшу переехали. Потом мы ж пожили у меня три месяца, зиму мы перезимовали. Ну, были записаны в [неразборчиво], конечно, такой организации евреев, с которой мы сейчас приехали.
David Boder: Агуда?
Clara Neiman: Агуда.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: В Лодзи. И мы решили...и потом [неразборчиво] нас взяли. Записались туда, и потом на зиму нельзя было с детями ехать, конечно, трудно.
Clara Neiman: И потом уже, в го...в ма...в апреле месяце мы уже выехали.
David Boder: А как же отец к Вам приехал?
Clara Neiman: А отец приехал, я ж написала ему.
David Boder: Вместе с мамой?
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: O.
Clara Neiman: Вместе с мамой семья, и сестра тоже с семьей, понятно?
David Boder: Так они что, как поляки приехали или [неразборчиво]?
Clara Neiman: Они...ну муж тоже как поляк.
David Boder: Хм.
Clara Neiman: . . . выехали. А у нее муж тоже [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: А мама...ну, разрешение было письменное в газете, что значит, если иметь в Польше сына или дочь, можно было выехать.
David Boder: Ага. Так.
Clara Neiman: Матери. Мать, значит, осталась как одна, старенькая.
David Boder: So.
Clara Neiman: . . . можно было выехать.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Так и братья тоже выехали...
Clara Neiman: Сейчас два брата у меня в иешиве есть здесь. Они решаются в Америку поехать. Они учатся в иешиве, в Люксембен. Город...
David Boder: Какой?
Clara Neiman: Немецкий, немецкий. Люксембен.
David Boder: Люксембург?
Clara Neiman: Люксембург, да.
David Boder: Они теперь в Люксембурге?
Clara Neiman: Они в иешиве, учатся.
David Boder: [неразборчиво]
Clara Neiman: Самые младшие. Младшие два брата.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Но они еще не выехали.
Clara Neiman: И таким образом мы сюда приехали. Уже живем здесь пять месяцев.
David Boder: А значит, вас два брата, моложе, учатся в Люксембургской иешиве.
Clara Neiman: Два брата, младше...учатся в иешиве.
David Boder: Это где? В Люксембурге?
Clara Neiman: В Люксембурге, да. Большая там есть иешива, они учатся там.
David Boder: А Вы...а почему Вы говорите, они в Америку собираются?
Clara Neiman: Они почему-то...у них уже и визы были на руках, но почему-то [неразборчиво] пока еще не уехали. Тока один из них решил уехать, а пока нам сообщили, значит, были два...два человека на этой неделе, прошлой неделе...
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: . . . и нам сообщили, пока они еще не уехали; чтоб мы написали им письмо.
David Boder: Ага. Ну, так.
Clara Neiman: Они еще не знают, или мама наша уехала.
David Boder: А они не знают, что мама Ваша...
Clara Neiman: Нет, ничего.
David Boder: А Вы уже письма получали?
Clara Neiman: А мы от мамы не получили. Почему они не пишут, я не знаю. А другие эти, которые уехали с мамой на этом пароходе, они пишут, что очень хорошо устроились в Тель-Авиве, а некоторые приехали молодежь в Кибутц. А некоторые остались [неразборчиво].
David Boder: А скажите, Вы разве не знаете еще, что Ваши родители попали в Палестину?
Clara Neiman: Они...Нет, мы знаем. Сообщили нам. Чехи сообщили нам, что этот пароход, который, значит, пришел [неразборчиво], они сообщили, что их освободили, некоторые поехали в Тель-Авив – вот они написали письмо,- а некоторые, значит...эээ...остались там [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Так. А от мамы Вашей Вы...
Clara Neiman: От мамы еще ничего.
David Boder: И от отца не получили?
Clara Neiman: Нет. Ничего.
David Boder: И от брата?
Clara Neiman: Ничего.
David Boder: Ага. Ну, а скажите-ка вот что: эээ...во время войны, значит, Вы были в Кутаисе?
Clara Neiman: Город Кутаис.
David Boder: И война туда не дошла?
Clara Neiman: Было два раза большое бомбардировка. Но всего два раза. Войны не было.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Около двадцать пять...сто двадцать пять километров было, вот.
Clara Neiman: Так.
David Boder: А потом наши погнали их обратно.
David Boder: Ага. И теперь Вы тут в Хенновиле с кем? С мужем?
Clara Neiman: С мужем и с ребенком.
David Boder: С одним ребенком. Это Ваша семья.
Clara Neiman: Да, наша семья. [Неразборчиво] и мальчик.
David Boder: А скажите, и как Вы тут живете? У Вас отдельные комнаты для семьи?
Clara Neiman: Отдельные. Все хорошо.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Все живы, слава Богу. Хорошо. Есть, что кушать, есть, что пить, чисто; все, можно сказать, хорошо.
Clara Neiman: Да.
David Boder: Эээ...Скажите-ка, Вы говорите, что у Вас с это...в Саратове или в Самаре Вы были?
Clara Neiman: Саратов. Город...Это недалеко.
David Boder: Да, в Саратове.
Clara Neiman: Да, это не очень...да, это Россия.
David Boder: И там у Вас было большое количество русских, которые стали евреями.
Clara Neiman: Да, но они тоже уехали, не остались.
David Boder: Так. А раввины у вас были кто?
Clara Neiman: В Саратове было много евреев.
David Boder: Так.
Clara Neiman: Вот это уже у мамы жила в Саратове, в городе Саратове, родная сестра. От этого она познакомилась, значит, с этими евреями вообще. И так она решила перейти в еврейство.
David Boder: Она не была замужем за евреем сначала?
Clara Neiman: Мама? Нет, нет, нет.
David Boder: Отец Ваш был чисто русским.
Clara Neiman: Да, да... нет, не чистые русские. Они были сектанты, потому...
David Boder: Ну да, я и говорю...
Clara Neiman: . . . они копались, копались, копались, копались, и решили перейти в...принять еврейскую веру, что нужно так верить - не так, как они верили.
David Boder: Ну, да.
Clara Neiman: И так они перешли.
David Boder: Ну, да. Эээ...а Вы по-еврейски тоже говорите?
Clara Neiman: [In Yiddish] קלאַראַ: איך רעד ייִדיש.
David Boder: באָדער: איר רעדט ייִדיש.
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: יאָ, איך רעד ייִדיש.
David Boder: באָדער: ווען האָט איר געלערנט ייִדיש?
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: איך...ווען איך האָב זיך געלערנט?
David Boder: יאָ.
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: ווען איך האָב געוווינט אין_________, האָבן מיר געוווינט אין אַ ייִדישער שטוב.
David Boder: וווּ?
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: אין אוקראַיִן. אין אוקראַיִן.
David Boder: באָדער: וווּ איז דאָס געווען?
Clara Neiman: [In Russian] Каменец-Подольск. Город Каменец-Подольск.
David Boder: Каменец-Подольск.
Clara Neiman: Подольск. [неразборчиво]
David Boder: [In Yiddish] באָדער: און מיט דעם קינד רעדט איר וואָס?
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: [רעדט אַ ביסל אויף רוסיש] נו, ייִדיש זאָל מען רעדן.
David Boder: נו.
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ: יע [לאַכט].
David Boder: באָדער: אַהאַ. און אײַער מאַן, וואָס טוט אײַער מאַן?
Clara Neiman: קלאַראַ:  [רעדט אַ ביסל אויף רוסיש]
David Boder: באָדער: קענט איר, קענט איר לייענען ייִדיש, Hebrew? קענט איר דאַוונען?
Clara Neiman: העברעיִש? ניין. איך דאַוון  אויף רוסיש. [רעדט אַ ביסל אויף רוסיש]
David Boder: וואָס האַט איר? אַ סירורמיט אַ פּעריוואָד?
Clara Neiman: יאָ. אַ סירור מיט אַ פּעריוואָד.
David Boder: [באָדער און קלאַראַ רעדן רוסיש צוזאַמען]
David Boder: נו, און ווען דענקט איר איר וועט שוין זײַן אין ארץ ישׂראל?
Clara Neiman: הלוואַי. מע ווייסט נאָך נישט. מע ווייסט נאָך נישט. הע, הע. הלוואַי וואָס גיכער. כ’וואָלט געוואָלט וואָס גיכער.
David Boder: אייערע פֿאַמיליע, אײַער פֿאָטער און אײַער מוטער זײַנען אַריבערגעגאַנגען אילעגאַל?
Clara Neiman: נישט לעגאַל.
David Boder: נישט לעגאַל. ווי זײַנען זיי אַוועקגעפֿאָרן? האָבן זיי געהאַט אַ שיף אָדער ווי...?
Clara Neiman: פֿון גאָרע...נאַ...
David Boder: מאַרסיי?
Clara Neiman: מאַרסיי, מאַרסיי.
David Boder: מאַרסיי.
Clara Neiman: דאָרטן זײַנען זיי אַ וואָך צײַט געווען, און זיי זײַנען אַוועקגעפֿאָרן. [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]  אַ סך מענטשן נישט. אַ גרויסע קאָמפּאַניע געווען.
David Boder: זײַנען אַלע אַרײַנגעקומען?
Clara Neiman: [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] יאָ. אַ סך מענטשן זײַנען געווען. אָפּגעזעסן אַ וואָך צײַט און דערנאָך זײַנען אַוועקגעפֿאָרן.
David Boder: זאָגט מיר, ווען זײַט איר אַוועקגעפֿאָרן פֿון רוסלאַנד? אין וועלכן יאָר?
Clara Neiman: אונדז זײַנען אַוועקגעפֿאָרן, איך וועל אײַך זאָגן [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] איך זאָל נישט פֿאַרגעסן...אונדז זײַנען אַוועקגעפֿאָרן...ס’איז שוין...פֿון רוסלאַנד קיין גרודיע[?] פֿרעגט איר?
David Boder: ניין, ניין, ניין. פֿון גרודיע. ווען זײַט איר אַוועקגעפֿאָרן קיין פּאָלאנד?
Clara Neiman: אַה, ,קיין פּוילן אַוועקגעפֿאָרן. מ’אַוועקגעפֿאָרן שוין וויפֿל? אַ יאָר צײַט. שוין אַ יאַר צײַט אַוועקגעפֿאָרן.
David Boder: שוין אַ יאַר צײַט. גוט.
Clara Neiman: [רעדט אַ ביסל אויף רוסיש].
David Boder: צו ערשט האָט איר געדאַכט צו בלײַבן אין פּאָלאַנד צו ערשט?
Clara Neiman: ניין. ניט [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] פֿאָרשטייט זיך. פֿון פּוילן  מענטשן האָבן געזען, אַז מע פֿאָרט...
David Boder: און ווי זײַט איר עץ געקומען נאַך פֿראַנקרײַך, דערציילט מיר?
Clara Neiman: ווי זענען מיר געפֿאָרן?  מיר זענען געקומען...מיר זענען געפֿאָרן קיין __צורק______ און געפֿונען עטלעכע מענטשן. מיר זענע געפֿאָרן __דאַס פּלאַ_____
David Boder: וואָס הייסט געפֿאָרן?
Clara Neiman: [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
Clara Neiman: [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] געפֿאָרן אין צוּוולאַק.
David Boder: אַהא.
Clara Neiman: און דאָרט זענען מיר געזעסן אַ חודש צײַט.
David Boder: יע. וווּ זײַט איר געזעסן ביז איצטער? אין אַ קאָמיטעט?
Clara Neiman: יע. אין אַ קאָמיטעט פֿון אגודה. ס’איז געווען עסן
David Boder: יע.
Clara Neiman: טרינקען.
David Boder: אָ, די אגודה האָט אײַך שוין גענומען פֿון...פֿון פּוילן.
Clara Neiman: פֿון לאָדזש, פֿון פּוילן, יאָ.
David Boder: .פֿון לאָדזש . יעס. זיי האַבן אײַך גענומען פֿון לאָדזש און פּלאַ
Clara Neiman: פֿון לאָדזש [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] און פֿון פלאַ. פֿון בריטאַן איז מען אויך געפֿאָרן דורך פּלאָ. מיט אויטאָבוס זענען מיר געפֿאָרן.
David Boder: מיט אויטאָבוסן זענט איר געפֿאָרן.
Clara Neiman: יאָ. ביז [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: ביז ווע...ביז פֿראַנקרײַך אין אויטאָבוסן?
Clara Neiman: יאָ.
David Boder: זענט איר דורכגעפֿאָרן דורך דײַטשלאַנד?
Clara Neiman: מיר זענען דורכגעפֿאָרן, יע. מיר זענען געפֿאָרן צו אונזערע ברידער.
David Boder: אָ.
Clara Neiman: מיר זענען געפֿאָרן...סיאיז געווען פֿאַר פּסח. איז אַזוי. אַראָפּגעפֿאָרן, הייסט עס...פֿיר טאָג האָבן מיר געפֿאָרן. די פּעק זענען געווען בײַ אונדז געווען פֿאַרטיק צו נאַכטס, יע? איז מיר געקומען דאָנערשטיק, אָנגעקומען אין פֿראַנקרײַך. און פֿרײַטיק זענען מיר שוין געווען אין האָטעל.
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Clara Neiman: און דאָרטן [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: איז ראַבײַ האָראָוויץ געוועזן?
Clara Neiman: נישט דאָ, נישט דאָ, נישט דאָ. מענטשן זענען געקומען שפּעטער...ער איז פֿריִער געקומען. עטלעכע פֿאַמיליעס זענען געווען אין פּאַריז אָבער  [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: נו.
Clara Neiman: אַזוי איז געווען פּסח אין פּאַריז  איז געווען גוט, געגעסן אין [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: נו, יאָ. און וואָס טוט איר אַפֿיר דאָ אַ גאַנצן טאָג?
Clara Neiman: דאָ. ס’איז סײַ גוט. נישט קיין ערגעניש. דער מאַן גייט אויפֿן גאָרטן אַרבעטן,  און איך האָב געגן קינד צו טאָן. איך קען נישט אַרבעטן.
David Boder: אָהאַ. און וווּ עסט איר? איר עסט אין...
Clara Neiman: אין סטאַלאָווע, אין סטאַלאָווע.
David Boder: אין סטאַלאָווע. אַלע צוזאַמען אָר עסט איר אַפּאַטשע און די מענער אַפּאַטשע?
Clara Neiman: [רעדט רוסיש]
David Boder: דאָס זעלבע ווי מע גייט צום דאַווענען, באַזונדער.
Clara Neiman: יאָ, פֿרישטיק [רעדט אַ ביסל רוסיש]
David Boder: זאָ, איר דאַרפֿט ניט קאָכן פֿאַר זיך זעלבס?
Clara Neiman: ניין.
David Boder: און פֿאַרן קינד?
Clara Neiman: ניין, פֿאַרן קינד קאָכט מען ניט. איך קען דאָך נישט נעמען דאָס קינד אין סטאַלאָווע. סיאיז בײַ מיר אַן אייוועלע קאָך איך אים אין שטוב בײַ מיר.
David Boder: איר האָט אַן אייוועלע? אַן עלעקטרישן אייוועלע?
Clara Neiman: [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: אַהאַ. און אײַער מאַן, אײַער מאַן איז אַ שנײַדער?
Clara Neiman: אַ גוטער שנײַדער: מאַנסקי דאַם. הע, הע. מאַנסקי ווי דאַם
David Boder: הע, הע. וואָס מיינט דאָס?
Clara Neiman: . פֿאַר אַ מאַן און פֿאַר אַ פֿרוי.
David Boder: [In Russian] О, мужской и дамский.
Clara Neiman: Мужской и дамский.
David Boder: Мужской и дамский портной.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] סאָ, אין פּאַלעסטין, אין ארץ־ישׂראל וואָס דענקט איר וועט איר טוען? איר וועט האָבן אַ שנײַדערײַ אָדער איר וועט אַרבעטן אויפֿן לאַנד?
Clara Neiman: ער, ס‘איז אים פֿאַרמיסט שנײַדערײַ. אין רוסלאַנד [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] שנײַדערײַ. עס געפֿעלט אים אויפֿן לאַנד.
David Boder: עס געפֿעלט אים. . .
Clara Neiman: אויף ערד, אויף ערד וועט ער גיין אַרבעטן.
David Boder: אַהאַ. נו, קלאַראַ אַדאַמאָוונאַ, דאָס איז זייער אינטערעסאַנט. ווירקלעך איר האָט גאַנץ נײַעס דערציילט און איך דענק, אַז מיר וועלן אַלע זײַן אינטערעסירט צו הערן.
David Boder: נאָך עפּעס וואָס וואָס איר וואָלט מיר דערציילן?  וואָס פֿאָרע אינטערעסאַנטע זאָכן וואָס איר האָט דערלעבט ווען אין דעם קריג?
Clara Neiman: [לאַכט]
David Boder: ווי אַלט איז אײַער ייִנגל יעצט?
Clara Neiman: איצט?  מײַן ייִנגל? אַנדערטהאַלבן יאָר.
David Boder: אַ יאָר?
Clara Neiman: יאָרץ...אַנדערטהאַלבן.
Clara Neiman: [In Russian] Полтора года.
David Boder: Полтора года.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] און ווי לאַנג זײַט איר פֿאַרהײַראַט?
Clara Neiman: איך? שוין דרײַ יאָר. אין פֿערטן יאַר.
David Boder: פֿערטן יאַר. קיין אַנדערע קינדער האָט איר שוין ניט געהאַט.
Clara Neiman: ניין, ניין. דאָס ערשטע קינד.
David Boder: דאָס ערשטע קינד.
Clara Neiman: אַ ייִנגל. [לאַכט] אַ גרויסער [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך].
David Boder: אַ גרויסער וואָס?
Clara Neiman: [לאַכט] אַ גרויסער [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך].
David Boder: וואָס איז דאָס?
Clara Neiman: נו, [רוסיש: סאַר ביסטרע [?]]
David Boder: אַהאַ. נו, איך דאַנק אײַך זייער
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mrs. Clara Adamovna Neiman, at Hénonville near Paris, in a Kibbutz, rather...of a rather religious organization. She is a representative of a Russian family which became converted to Judaism through Molokanism, not for motive of marriage. And she was brought up as a Jew by her parents. And, eh...Her parents are already now in Palestine, and [so is] one brother. Oh, yes...
David Boder: [In Yiddish] איר האָט מיך אָבער ניט געזאָגט: ווי האָט איר זיך געזען אין דײַטשלאַנד מיט אײַערע ברידער?
Clara Neiman: [In  Russian] Ага, мы это пропустили.
David Boder: Ну, говорите по-русски.
Clara Neiman: Мы заехали...Значит так было: мы спешили, мы заехали, нам нужно было переночевать.
David Boder: Куда Вы заехали?
Clara Neiman: Мы ехали в город Люк...
David Boder: Люксембург?
Clara Neiman: [In Yiddish]  קיין לעקסינבורג, יאַ. ס’איז געווען [רעדט רוסיש]. דאָרט [?] גייט מײַן מאַן אין שיל אַרײַן. דאָרט געווען איין גרויסער [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: יאָ.
Clara Neiman: מײַן מאַן גייט אַרײַן. ער איז געגאַנגען פֿריִער דאַוונען. [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך]
David Boder: מההם.
Clara Neiman: [עטלעכע ווערטער אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] ער איז ארײַנגעגאַנגען אין שיל. ער זאָגט  ס’דאָ אַ פּאָר יונגע גערע.
David Boder: יאָ.
Clara Neiman: עס איז דאָ אין שיל אַ גרויסער לערער וואָס לערנט זייער גוט. נו, גיכער איז דער מאַן צוגעלאָפֿן און דערזען, אַז ס׳איז טאַקע אונדזערע ברידער. [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך־־אָבער איר קול איז פֿול מיט שׂמחה).
David Boder: אַהאַ.
Clara Neiman: [אַ ביסל אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] זיי האָבן זיך שיין אָנגעטאָן. זיי האָבן  גוט אויסגעזען, [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] גוט.
David Boder: און זיי וועלן גיין נאָך אַמעריקע.
Clara Neiman: איך ווייס נישט. . [אומפֿאַרשטענדלעך] אַוודאי. זיי וועלן גיין נאָך אַמעריקע.
David Boder: נו, אַ דאַנק אײַך זייער.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.